okay so welcome everybody to today's
meeting of the licensing
subcommittee um
make sure everything's okay
and we're going to consider the
variation to a premises license at the
family shopper
which is five to seven west cliff road
in ramsgate
my name is james clapson and i'm acting
as the meeting facilitator
and i'll conduct the election of
chairman so it can have a nomination
please
i'd like to nominate councillor brenda
rogers
okay thank you councillor schwab and the
second up
yeah our second match james okay thank
you council huxley
um in that case uh councillor rogers has
been being elected chair of the
licensing subcommittee so i'll pass over
to you thank you very much
thank you good morning everyone welcome
to this meeting
prior to this meeting all participants
have previously checked that they can be
heard and seen
and can see and hear other members to
double check this and to introduce
everyone who is present at this remote
meeting
i will kindly ask that you confirm your
attendance and your role
or job title when i say your name
amanda berry good morning amanda berry
environmental health officer
ivan goldsmith
i think ivan's just doing the recording
isn't he yeah
right i've got them on my screen um
alison brock
allison licensing officer charles
hungley
charles appears to have frozen at the
moment
we'll go on to councillor shrub horizon
yeah councillor for cliftonville east
and on the committee for licensing
james has already introduced himself so
we're going to uh karina huxley
hi i'm a counselor for eastfield ford in
ramsgate and i'm on the licensing
committee as well
and jennifer lips good morning i'm
jennifer
phillips i'm the principal litigation
lawyer for
hannah district council thank you
um charles are you about now
no i think he's frozen still and we've
got charles holden senior democratic
officer um
right and myself of course brenda rogers
i'm the
deputy board chairman
thank you um
let's see where we are if you have any
technical difficulties during the
meeting
then please contact katie democratic
services officer
on call who will attempt to assist you
they will put their phone numbers in the
chat function
i would ask participants when you're not
speaking please
mutual microphones this minimizes
background noise
and will help everyone listen to the
proceedings microphones may only be on
if the participant has been granted
permission to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
briefly indicate on the
chat on the right side of the screen and
i will then make a note and go back to
you once the person speaking has
finished
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are cloned
silent and they are not used to make or
receive phone calls while the meeting is
in progress
do not turn off your phones in case you
need to be contacted in event of
technical difficulties
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting other business
and ensure that you're in a quiet room
and free from distractions of the
meeting
please note that this meeting is being
live streamed for members of the public
except for the private deliberation part
of the meeting in this instance a
separate private hangout meeting will
take place
for that item only and the public
meeting will
resume in the previous digital digital
location 30 minutes later
unless there is reason to suggest an
earlier or later time
no unauthorized recording of this
confidential item of business is
permitted to take place
right um apologies for absence
are there any apologies for absence
i'll get sorry i'll give michelle's
thank you um decorations of interest
um are there any declarations of
interest
no thank you what gender item four
this is an application for
hang on sorry i lost that application
for a variation to the premises license
at family shopper
five to seven west cliff road rams gate
i call a crop
on with calc with licensing officer
thank you morning everyone um
well i was contacted by the agent uh
following the
arrangement of this meeting um because
he was unable to get the legal
representative he
wanted i had a chat with legal
department jennifer
and we agreed to adjourn today's hearing
and arrange for another day
the hearing has to be held under the
hearing rights by the 27th of november
therefore i'd like to suggest the 24th
because i know we've got a licensing
board
arranged for that day which there is no
uh there's no items for so we could take
that date for
this hearing if everyone's happy with
that
thank you very much uh please
please don't have a problem
propose for a second will join the
meeting please here i'll propose to
being a
adjournment thank you councillor schwab
i
proposed it on a second uh i'll second
that
sure thank you councillor huxley
um thank you this meeting will now
adjourn will reconvene at a future day
thank you very much thank you sweet
thank you